on December 14th hitting New York New
York the crane theater once again I
Never Promised You a Rose Garden
bringing the show down to Austin Texas
January 13th and 14th at the Vulcan and
then New York again Levittown New York
at Governors January 20th and 21st come
and check out all these shows more being
added all the time stay tuned get all
your Show tickets and all your show info
joeinfo.com also please check out we'll
see you in hell my movie podcast with
Pat Walsh we are over at we'll see uh
I'm sorry we're at patreon.com
wsiyhpodcast you can get all the new
episodes there and the back catalog is
available online wherever you get your
podcasts and finally Joey Rose's my barn
sandwich shop is now open seven days a
week at 11 30 a.m every day drinks and
sandwiches all day long come through
thank you for the support we've turned a
year old I can't believe we made it this
is amazing thank you guys we couldn't
have done it without you come come see
us and if you want info about the bar
and sandwich shop
joeyrosesnyc.com thank you
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds folks welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds Joe DeRosa your taste
buds podcast don't worry I'm not solo
again all right this is it was a
one-time deal uh this guest actually
showed up welcome to the show Ian Lara
how you doing buddy I'm good man thank
you for having me yeah of course I came
I wasn't gonna miss this I came through
the bad weather and everything you did
yes you are committed to promoting your
special right I'm a professional yes now
I feel like I need to be more Divas I'm
like should I be missing is that where
the cool people are doing no podcast
should I be doing it you should not be
missing anything
now I'm like a newbie you gotta like act
like you've been here just cancel
I would say this with regarding you
being here and Steve missing his episode
your special HBO Steve's
Amazon Prime
what if if one of you did have more of a
right to skip it's you well well that's
nice it's nice to hear thank you I'll
take it I'll take whatever I can get
uh let's talk for a little bit about the
special okay because uh you know let's
do it I know we're here to argue about
food sure but let's let's and I'm
honestly more passionate about that than
the special but so let's get this good
special talk out the way uh tell us
about it where can people see it it's on
HBO Max HBO Max uh romantic comedy Ian
Lara romantic comedy is up there is uh
not to brag the number two stream
special last two weeks on the things
little Rel is in front of me I'm trying
to beat him that's great uh just go up
there and watch it's like that's a
formidable person to be you know
formidable adversary little rels he's
one of my favorite comedians yeah he's
one of my favorite I've watched this
like three times huge waves it's not
like yeah it's not like you're like this
new kid nobody ever heard of is in front
of me right right yeah I've actually
watched his three times and I haven't
watched mine so just help me out and
that was great give it a good yeah I
love bro
um but yeah it's up there HBO Max we
filmed it in July here in New York
directed by another comedian Idol
Rodriguez
um you know oh nice yeah it's been good
that's great yeah to check it out that's
awesome man uh congrats that's awesome
thank you man thank you I appreciate it
I'm happy for you and you can did you
just say this you can watch it on Demand
right yeah yes it's screaming there
it'll be there for the forever so you
got to do it on HPD HMO Max app yeah I
think that's the only way it was on HBO
now yeah I think that's the only way you
could watch HBO now right I I don't know
I don't have cable I have no idea yeah
we're talking about this earlier I don't
know
when I see like uh
people will like post like I saw the
show to Comedy Central I'm like is that
it still exists I don't I don't say this
[ __ ] on Comedy so I'm like I don't
understand what anything is anymore it's
gotten are there like do people sit and
go I'm gonna watch this Channel at this
time to see a show that I like I can't
even in New York for sure no but I guess
there's a part of the country that still
does it so it's formidable it's funny
because I feel like At first Netflix was
like the thing was like a streaming and
then a bunch of screaming Services came
out now they're uniting so it's like is
this just cable are we just gonna go
back to Cable where everyone's do you
just get a package of all the channels
and they're going back a bunch of weak
releases too yeah yeah like like now HBO
not I don't think Netflix is doing it
yet but like HBO don't understand it
with stranger things there's three
episodes at a time yeah it's just weekly
watch episode release now so yeah that's
I mean you you know look nobody's it's
gonna just the pendulum is going to
swing back and forth and back and forth
yeah people are going to complain
that releasing all of it at once was too
much which they did eventually they was
the greatest thing in the world and then
it was like oh but we're not parsing it
out enough yeah now they start parsing
it out I read an article like about
Andor the Star Wars show uh where it's
like here's why it's a problem that
Andor is releasing things only three
only one episode it's like okay you know
what I mean like it's so then it'll
swing back to to batch releases again
and then it'll say but the thing that's
most interesting to me about all this is
the Weird Al movie that he did uh like
it but it was released I was kind of
scratching my head at first I was like
I understand it's just released to Roku
and like you don't even need you didn't
even need a uh
uh what's it called with it you didn't
even need a a a a profile
because like I think it's real it might
be Roku there's like a new one that has
like pretty good stuff on it but people
don't know like and it's free [ __ ] oh I
think it's 2B I think it's true yeah
to me if you like old like we like like
horror movies and yeah you know but they
got like original programming now like
they got I think like Pete Davidson is
that Roku I don't know what it is T
Davidson had a show John Mulaney had a
show on it I believe uh I can't speak I
don't know yeah but Roku well Roku
definitely has original stuff because
they did the Weird Al movie but here's
the thing you didn't need an app or
anything and you didn't need to log into
anything you could go to the Roku
website on your computer or TV and just
watch it yeah that was it you just
clicked on it and launched it and I was
like this doesn't make any sense like
what and then I realized like oh no wait
it has commercials yeah this is like how
cable this is this cable this is like a
better version of cable because you can
still watch it in demand but it has
commercials so you don't pay for it
that's what 2B does yeah 2B is
completely free a hundred percent it's
on demand but it has commercials and is
there an app because I like an app
2B has an app and I think Roku probably
does too yeah I know I know Roku does
yeah I like an app I like a cool app
where like an easy one though I also got
to be honest with you I don't mind there
are certain things I mine commercials on
if it's too many it's it's a bit of a
drag
um but like usually with things I don't
mind uh I I really don't mind
um
the the commercials because I there's
something about like when I got rid of
cable and it was just streaming it was
very much like
I felt like kind of like a little
disconnected yeah you know what I mean
and then I would watch like sometimes
I'll go on YouTube but for Nostalgia and
I'll watch like commercials from the
eight Christmas commercials from the 80s
or whatever and like where where you
watch those on YouTube they have like
commercial compilations oh you can
literally put in like yeah I've heard of
that yeah you could put in like toy
commercials from the 90s
um that's pretty cool and just you know
go through it and uh and and it's it's
great it's nostalgic you're like oh yeah
I remember I remember this
and when I got rid of cable there was a
part of me that missed there's something
connective about like I know they're
just trying to sell me something but
there is a finger on the pulse element
to see yes how commercials are made like
what they're selling how they're selling
it
even what products are you know even
just hearing like the way people talk
like there's there's like phrases in the
discourse that you that you don't
realize like oh that's like a popular
phrase yeah I would never would have
known that but these I've heard it in
these three commercials or whatever you
know what I mean I actually I still have
cable I have everything I have I have
cable and every streaming app I'm like a
weird I like I'm I I'm like loyal to
Brands and I'll just yeah yeah I'm
pretty loyal yeah I'm loyal too I just
with cable for me it was like the the
Box annoyed me after a while and then I
had the cable streaming apps for a while
but whole cable they don't even do the
Box no more like I have cables nobody
it's just it's just an app there you go
that's the last thing right cable I've
done this like sling yeah yeah I know
sling but I never watch it enough that I
that's what I did I just I end up going
only excuse me to the on-demand stuff
yes and then I go
well what am I doing I got this so I
could have cable but then I never
watched the cable part and then there's
no point to this I I never watch it
either but like I'm just too loyal like
I tried to disconnect it I called and
they were like do you really want to do
this and I was like all right I guess
I'll just stay with it and I ended up
like upgrading it's toxic yeah
I don't know I'll tell you the biggest
thing I I miss about uh I miss about
cable or commercials you know and not
seeing them regularly
uh and I see it on YouTube now because I
follow so many Foodies on YouTube the
the releases at fast food restaurants
that's the new sandwich yeah I mean I
know what's out there I'm up to date on
those [ __ ]
I subscribe to a newsletter what'd you
think about McDonald's pitching you you
can buy your own french fry holder
that's plastic like reusable french
fries yeah it's like McDonald's trying
to be green yes I don't know I mean look
look you're gonna get one I mean I look
at this apartment you're gonna have a
review yeah french fry holder for sure
collecting the toys where are the toys
that'll be up here for sure I got the
well I don't think Happy Meal toys I
don't collect them fans bring them to me
which is very nice it's very cool I got
some I got a really cool uh vintage when
she gave it to me I was like this is
worth money don't give me this and she
was like I mean this might be the
coolest apartment I've ever seen Bam Bam
well I'm a big believer and the grid
will go down one day yeah and uh here we
go and I'm a big believer I got that
Vibe for me I'm just a believer when I
walked in here this guy thinks doomsday
is coming I saw that well it's not in
all honesty it's it's not like it's not
a doomsday thing it's just a I don't
like I like to own my own stuff I I
don't like how many times has your cable
not worked I'm sorry your internet not
worked yeah how many times is your cell
phone not doing what you wanted to be
doing how many times is your laptop or
iPad acting wonky they're asking for the
update they're asking for this right for
that sure I like to be in control of my
media I like to collect media I value
media I mean we work in the media
business I have a great admiration for
this like these box sets like the box
that's under my TV it's like yeah and
there's thousands of more cases in here
too well that's my video game how many
DVDs how many discs are in this space
right here I have no idea 10 000. do you
have an iPhone not that many yeah do you
now I hate I've grown video game boxes
would you collect the iPhones like from
the phone no that's a cool collection
you know they just sold like original
iPhone just sold I think for like
hundreds of thousand dollars yeah it was
in the box like iPhone one somebody had
I don't have any interest in that side
of it not selling it but it was cool
yeah yeah yeah if you just pulled out an
iPhone one that would be very cool yeah
yeah it's a question for Joe what what's
gonna happen with all this when you go
is this is when I die yeah shred it
honestly I would leave it I would leave
it to somebody that would appreciate it
like a younger person
or I would donate those people I would
literally donate it to a store that that
trades and this sort of stuff and say
like I'm donating you this like but
don't just sell it they want to
appreciate it I wouldn't I don't think I
would say I would sell this if I've
thought about like oh I was like oh I
could open a maybe not a store but I was
like I could open a media section in
somebody else's store my friend Meg for
a little while she had a secondhand
store yeah and she was like you should
open a video game counter at my store
and I was like I actually have enough
stuff that I could do that yeah I've
thought about doing that
because here's the thing at this point
this has all become very decorative the
discs I use I do pull these movies off
the shelf and watch them really yeah and
I will at times hook these older systems
up to the TV to play them but the
emulation is getting easier and easier
and easier to do and I do all I can to
support the brands and spend my money
with the brands I will always buy the
physical media but at the end of the day
when you just feel like playing
something and you don't feel like making
a big production out of it you will go
to the emulation and just go it's just
so much easier to just do this this way
right now yeah and become a production
like you said what about this though
what about you ever thought about
opening a vintage bar I did this cool
stuff no but yeah but but wait wait no
my boss I know it is but like just
completely like video game you have TVs
with like the old commercials playing
like that's almost what we do at Joey
Rose is it there's just not a there's
not a firm like most of the time what
plays on the TV are Throwback horror
movies yeah most of the time yeah all
the decoration direct every decoration
on every wall is is a vintage item yeah
there's Atari games on display there's
old video discs on display uh the shelf
above the bar is entirely made up of
vintage yeah I know I knew it was a
vintage book yeah I've never been to Joy
Rose because here's my thing and we
could get into the food thing because I
holy [ __ ] hurricane wow what is
yeah
um it's the wind it's very bad Jesus
it's really bad all right well maybe I
should have some empathy for Steve no he
went to do his podcast he's not like he
but he's a coaster
[Laughter]
well this is actually I'll let me give
Pat a plug yeah Pat country the uh NES
Punk which is is his YouTube character
and he was a very very popular can I
have the coaster yeah yes why are you
plug this all right thank you he's a
very very popular YouTube personality uh
but pet country and I've become friends
this is an amazing book he wrote that is
the complete history of the Nintendo
Entertainment System he reviews every in
this book every product not review it's
more like write-ups yeah but you know
every game and product for every
Nintendo everything Nintendo ever made
he did one on Super Nintendo which I
also have yeah and he's out there I
think he's working on a third one no
it's in the other room do you have a PS5
it's an incredible feat of work this
book yeah yeah it's up there all right
yeah I thought you were one of those
guys that were like I'm not doing
anything new everything is just no man I
love I love media my the media I love is
music video games and movies so I buy
that's what I was saying with the
iPhones it's just that type of
Technology doesn't really I don't care
as much yeah uh I'm just but I buy I buy
I still buy cassettes and Records uh I I
do have a I have a extensive hip-hop CD
collection yeah I was looking at your
tapes over there which is in storage my
hip-hop tapes that's my prize like kind
of whatever I've been collect those
since I was a kid yeah I do like vinyl
because I like the way it sounds I like
cassettes I like the way they sound I
like the experience of putting a
cassette tape in CD collector man yeah
CDs I only have hip hop because I feel
like hip-hop sounds its best on CD and
I'm such a big hip-hop fan so that's
cool
yeah yeah and and stuff that throws back
to old school you're not listening like
to Lil Uzi vert now oh my God little
little Uzi on this show we should do
that nothing against little nothing
against little Uzi
what about 21 Savage you listening to
the 21 no you wouldn't like I mean I
don't know I don't know any other music
he disrespected Nas and you wouldn't
like that probably it was wild no but
now he didn't disrespect them he just
said nauseous respected Pete Rock which
I didn't care for yeah but then P Rock
was kind of like I don't know why not
said that man yeah like and so I don't
know who's right or who's wrong but yeah
uh uh but whatever
uh but yes I would I would tend to get
NASA's back before 21 Savage 21 Savage
yeah he's the youngest rapper you're a
fan of yeah
probably Joey Badass oh okay yeah okay
yeah you know I like all those guys I
like Aesop oh the holy Savage ASAP and
all those guys like I like all that
stuff I just
but those guys have I mean I love
Kendrick okay okay you know it's like
but those guys are not the guys you're
referring to I can already tell is like
the it's like the
[Music]
um
are you okay
but you know what I'm talking about
speech yeah I know what you're talking
about it's like Mumble raps yeah and
then they Auto-Tune the voice yeah it's
just you know whatever man like nothing
against it but it's all it just one
thing emulates the next it's like nobody
really
you know uh even the throwback wrap I
like they don't really emulate somebody
they just like you know I always talk
about Czar face Czar face
you know it's like they sound
they sound like a throwback to New York
in the in the in in the 90s but they put
their modern spin on it and and it's
it's still inspector deck and and
esoteric and they've got their own
Styles and and dj7
L like he does all his you know he's
unique like so there's a uniqueness to
it still it's not it's not a copy thing
it's just of in the vein of yeah you
know I like um run the jewels you know
okay again look there's there's a
there's a nod to older stuff but they
sound modern you seem like you're
willing to
go along because you have to evolve
sometimes the old school hip-hop guys
they just wanted to be the 90s and it's
like you have to evolve like you're a
dinosaur like just if you like that
music listen to that music but you can't
make 90s music in 2023. well look man I
say it about you you can you just have
to understand what the lane for that
music is yeah and it's very small you
can't get bitter about it you can't you
know look I look I always say this with
art
with any kind of art you can make if
you're good and you're committed and it
might take you a long time but if you're
good at what you do and you're committed
and you don't [ __ ] it up with
pissing everybody off or drugs doing too
much I'm not against drugs sure
but doing too many drugs drinking too
much
whatever whatever your your
self-destructive thing may be yeah if
you're good and you're committed to your
to your work
and you don't [ __ ] it up with one of
those three things
you can make eventually
sooner or later an accountant's wage
doing this there's no shame in that yeah
there's no shame in that this concept
that like you failed unless you're
buying a mansion uh in cash and you're
nominated for this so that you can
Aspire for those things but the idea
that you're a failure if you don't do
those things is very short-sighted to me
is very stupid
um that's a pretty good perspective you
know and that's the thing like you can
you can make you can make 90s you can
make hip-hop that sounds like it's from
1978 if you want you know what I mean
and
that's the
I don't think it's being a well I here's
the difference to me between a throwback
and a dinosaur I think a dinosaur
doesn't understand what it is he's doing
okay
a throwback person goes yeah I like this
this look Joey Badass his entire first
few records were like yeah maybe at
least first too they were boom bap
records yeah he was like I'm gonna do
stuff like primo and I'm gonna you know
DJ Premiere greatest producer in my
opinion in all hip-hop ever uh he is in
and of himself now almost a throwback
yeah like his style of production is not
a modern approach to production by any
stretch but Premiere supports all the
Young Dudes he that's not that's not
what a dinosaur does what a dinosaur
does is go I'm this and you have all
failed me that's what a dinosaur does
yeah so I told the guys I'm talking
about more guys of course of course so
that's why I say some guys are like that
and some guys are but I but but here's
the thing I say it about comedy all the
time comedy's the same way right
comedy's the same way people you know
like there's Comics who try to do 90s
comedy and it's like 80 it's like you
can't talk like that anymore
well it's it's funny man because I go
back and forth with the I'm a big uh I'm
a big Free Speech advocate here we go
but uh
relax I knew we'd go down this path
remember we're having HBO special I have
to play no yeah now you go too far you
gotta act like yeah yeah
no but here's the thing I'm a big I'm a
big advocate but I'm also a Believer
intact and Grace so like you know I
understand that there's a I have my
boundaries everybody's got their
boundaries everybody can have their own
boundaries I don't try to enforce my
boundaries on anybody else my boundaries
apply to my show period that's it so
same my take is this
you know I say all the time about you
know once so comment you'll hear a
completely hear a lot about stand up as
people say well the clubs are too
just these young kids so PC and they're
uh so the crowds get too offended now
and this and that and I go who's saying
that like all the comics say that where
people Comics oh oh yeah yeah the comics
are like people are two PC well well
yeah or like or like the young Comics
are too soft or this or that or whatever
and like there's there's a certain truth
to that I get it you know but you know I
think track I think that the the art of
trashing a comedian is a useful useful
comedian getting trashed by the last
episode it thickens your skin and this
is a business where you need some thick
skin so I'm not against all that but my
point is this I always say
I had my time in the clubs in the New
York clubs sure my show is my show I go
and do that on the road or wherever but
I had my time in the New York clubs in
the Showcase rooms I will
Steve Byrne pip can you grab that yeah
folks I would like to talk about one of
our newer sponsors
it's loamy
by Pila loamy by Pila I like loamy by
Pila because what they do is they do
composting they help you turn food waste
into dirt with the Press of a button
with loamy uh it's great the uh there I
mean here's the thing uh a lot of us
throw a lot of waste away a lot of us uh
would like to do something more with
that food waste than just throw it in
the trash where it just rots and smells
and and honestly goes to no real good
use
uh and a lot of us have heard of this
concept of composting and stuff but
perhaps we're stifled uh to to pursue
the the the process because of space
uh maybe you live in a city like I do
for instance maybe you don't have a yard
we can put a composting bin
uh maybe you do have a yard but maybe
your yard's got other stuff in it all
right I know I've always wanted to do
composting I just never had as a
manhattanite a yard space to do so
uh and also as a manhattanite I get
tired of throwing out so much food waste
because it's it's number one it's it
gets gross quick you have to turn those
garbage bags over fast uh and then
you're wasting even more because now
you're not even filling up full garbage
bags uh because you're just trying to
get the garbage out before it starts to
smell and starts to get disgusting
uh and then also too you know we all
hear that things are going on with the
environment we all want to do our share
uh and I think composting is a pretty
easy way to do it where you can see your
results I like that I like that you can
actually see what's happening you're not
sitting here guessing that uh or hoping
that what you're doing is making a
change you're actually doing something
by turning your food waste into dirt and
that's where alomi helps all right it
allows you to turn those food scraps
into dirt as I said with a push of a
button to countertop electric composter
and it turns the stuff over in four
hours that's it or just under actually
and there's no smell uh when it runs and
it's really quiet uh isn't that great
all of these things I'm saying
eco-conscious less garbage composting
great there you go you're doing it
you're creating soil instead of waste so
if you want to start making a positive
environmental impact or just make clean
up after dinner that much easier all
right you could be either way or both
whatever loamy is perfect for you head
to loamy that's lomi.com taste buds and
use promo code taste buds to get fifty
dollars off your loamy product the thing
that does it for you that's 50 bucks off
below me when you head to lomi.com taste
buds and use promo code taste buds at
checkout food waste is gross loamy is
your solution with the holidays just
around the corner loamy will make the
perfect gift also for someone on your
shopping list
checking nobody's on stage talking about
blow jobs and everybody's like brilliant
it's like give me a [ __ ] break all
right ready
folks
are you bespoked
are you I wish it was Halloween and why
during Halloween did I not call this
bespooked post
bespoke post people great company
and now they're delivering a winter
lineup of must-have items in their box
of awesome collections bespoke post
here's how it works they partner with
small businesses and emerging Brands and
they bring you the most unique Goods
they can every month I get a lot of
stuff from bespoke post and they send me
a lot of really cool stuff I got a
really cool pocket knife recently from
then I got a really cool like it's weird
to say Artisan keychain but it kind of
is a weirdly Artisan keychain
um
that doesn't Bend or break you know it's
like this this metal thing that's very
durable which you know I I bust my
keychains up a lot because I have 18
different jobs and I'm running around
the city all day and I have all these
different keys and my keychain actually
gets wear and tear
um I got a thing uh uh uh to to smoke uh
uh you can smoke like booze with it and
stuff uh or you can smoke food with it
it's really cool uh they just they just
send you this really really cool stuff
I'll tell you some other stuff that I
didn't get that you might want to check
out or or rather some uh yeah here you
go carnivore uh the American barbecue
rub is it comes in a carnivore box I've
gotten uh uh I got a great overnight bag
from them
um it's it's just very cool Artisan
durable unique stuff that's the coolest
part is that it's Unique meaning you
know you're not going to see 87 other
people with this thing but also too that
means it's helping again an emerging
brand or a young company uh that's what
makes it unique these are not big box
brands I really think it's cool all
kinds of different uh there's all kinds
of different uh products and and themed
boxes you can get uh there's the Terra
box which there's a knife in the Terra
box that's made by Bare Bones uh by Bare
Bones which is the company based in Salt
Lake City there's the Weekender box
which features metal hardware reinforced
then there's the Weekender which is a
bag the Weekender features metal
hardware a reinforced frame quality
leather straps that's the one I have
it's great uh there's a gut hook knife
in the trail box that's made by Titan
International located in Illinois
um you know it's just very cool uh so
anyway you want to get started go take a
quick quiz at box of awesome.com and
your answers are going to help them pick
the right box of awesome for you you're
going to get 20 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter the code taste
buds at checkout that's box of
awesome.com enter promo code tastebuds
for twenty percent off your first box
box of awesome.com code taste buds
anyway
I say this I see this all the time like
I had my time in the New York showcase
clubs I'll still go through and do my
sets if if if if if I need to or
whatever
and I'll still go hang out sometimes but
I am not going in there expecting it to
be what it was six years ago ten years
ago yeah and I think people that do are
very short-sighted and that speaks to
your dinosaur point it's like it's like
I'm gonna go sit at a club and complain
that the young kids at the club now
don't want to talk about these things or
they want to get offended or they do
want to talk about those things or or
that it's boring or this or it's dead or
right oh it used to be so great it's
like no it used to be my time right and
the kids that are in there now are going
to look back at it and go remember when
it was so great when it was our time
right and there's going to be people
calling them dinosaurs at some point
sure be a dinosaur for sure I would be
but you don't you you might not be you
might be an open-minded evolving person
why you just complain like I'll just
complain like behind closed doors you
know it's like a normal American I don't
see the need to go out publicly but but
sometimes like and I don't know I guess
I'm in the middle thing because I
started in 2011 so I remember when I
started like you were in the clubs heavy
like you were like running around doing
other things before you went out
um to LA but sometimes when they be like
all these young Comics are too soft I'm
like
I'm just talking about what I want to
talk about like I've never was like oh
let me not touch this topic it's
offensive it's like I just don't want to
talk about that like if you want to make
your edgy joke about whatever you want
to make it make it but I just don't want
to talk about that right that's not me
being soft like I'm not soft I'm a like
right New York guy I grew up in South
Jamaica Queens like there's nothing
right really that's like I don't get
offended but I just don't want to talk
about that right right yeah no I agree
with that too and I I think most people
I don't think when anybody says that
comedians are soft or whatever they're
talking about a guy like you in any way
shape or form I think they're talking
about comedians that get offended by
things yeah or instruct other comedians
on how they should be yeah I've seen
that yeah which which fine but again
here's my take I don't care if every new
comic is doing this if but it's it's not
even that to me to me it's like if every
new comic comes out and says what we do
in comedy Now is we dress like priests
and nuns and we cross our legs and
you've seen my one-hour show huh yeah
yeah
and clench our pearls and get offended
and and go to six yeah well hey man
that's what the comedy scene is now so
I'll go do my show over here and if you
want to see my show over here where it's
my show
you're welcome to come and I hope you
enjoy it but I'm not gonna go sit in the
place where the nuns and Priests sit and
go this should be different God damn it
it should be this it should be that
that's that's the part I'm like did you
guys see that that comedian who uh had a
kick a Heckler like a Heckler sprinted
at him and he just kicked him straight
in the chest I'm thinking these are
playing now because people's careers are
blowing up off people charging that's a
good plan you wanna make some clips yeah
I need somebody to charge the stage I
had a thing at the stand where uh uh
this little black kid just ran in but it
was in the upstairs room and I was like
if we were downstairs this would have
been an amazing clip right he just ran
in and was like yelling like he was like
five years old he was like give me candy
and I was like this would have been
great for my Tick Tock but that's cute
yeah it's really cute it didn't get
recorded but I I'll also say like I
don't know I mean as a as a student of
Comedy I also find like it's evolved so
like what was like 70s 80s 90s edgy
became Norm so it kind of flipped where
it's like some comedians think they're
being like edgy but it's like you're
just doing 70s comedy right you're not
being no there's plenty of guys doing
that but that's where the dinosaur thing
comes in that's what I mean yeah that's
there's and that's what I mean by
there's a difference between somebody
who doesn't who's stuck in their ways
yeah versus somebody that says I don't
really know what a throwback of Comedy
would be like you know it's actually a
good example
he's not a throwback he's he's from the
era but like you know somebody wants uh
uh [ __ ] on Seinfeld to me yeah and they
go oh it's so outdated and I go no it's
not comedy has different colors sure
Seinfeld music Seinfeld is like an old
crooner yeah he's not you want punk rock
out of Seinfeld right no yeah you're
going to see Tony Bennett sure the guy's
a [ __ ] Legend man he did it he Tony
Bennett isn't coming out with leather
vests on and [ __ ] like that yeah you
know what I'm saying and eye tattoos
right you know so like
to make yeah so it's just not for you
but like I watch I just but I see he's
bumped me many times and I'm like this
is good like you can't argue that this
is not good com like I think you could
do less of the bumping personally that's
just my take yeah yeah what are you
gonna do I don't think he needs to do as
much bumping as he does but what are you
gonna do sometimes you find you're like
are these they're like there's a phase
you're like are they looking at like
what name on the lineup looks bumpable
and I was like this person looks soft
let me just let me just
it's it's confusing to me but I was
there was one night where I there was
one night where I got bumped four times
in three different clubs by who like I I
got bumped by Chris Rock at this one
seller Chappelle around the block and
then I went to Gotham and got bumped by
Seinfeld and then I was just getting
bumped everywhere I went I was just
getting [ __ ] up at least
I will say that I was like no they
called they had a call about this they
were like yo what are you doing tonight
let's all bumpy and Lara I can't I can't
speak to Chris because I don't know
Chris yeah very well I met him a few
times I can't but I haven't interacted
with him I've been I've never been
bumped by him I can't speak to it I have
been bumped by Seinfeld yeah and I have
been bought by Chappelle yeah me too I
could say here's the difference there's
a big deal Chappelle will go pack your
body Chappelle bumps you pack your bags
called an Uber go home but also too
Chappelle's a kind of gotta go oh man
I'm sorry oh man um you know yeah
Chappelle will give you at least that
yeah Seinfeld will bump you without even
saying hello he yeah I mean he was yeah
he didn't acknowledge at all but you
know I get it you know he signs up ever
saw what he did to Kesha when she tried
to hug him yeah that was great that was
on his side on that one that was amazing
I I listen I'm a big sign of up yet I
just he bought me when I had the flu
yeah and I had to headline and he did 35
minutes and then brought George Wallace
on to do 20 and I was just sitting there
and I was so it's a great show and I was
like I was like the least this guy could
do is say I'm sorry you're sick I'm
sorry this is happening Yeah just
something yeah can you acknowledge it
it's it
Rose is stewing in the corner I was too
sick dude I was literally laying at
Gotham like this and then I had to go on
and do my 45 minutes I had to go on and
do it and I had a great show but with
the flu it was wild but your flu game
yeah yeah
um I had one time I got bumped by bird
and this just to say like how nice he is
I was headlined and doing an hour and he
came in while the feature was on and I
was like you can go next obviously do
whatever you want to do and he was like
no I'll she's like do your thing do
however you're long I'll watch and then
you bring me up and I did 50 minutes he
waited 50 minutes and then I brought him
up that's great Jeff Ross did that when
I was in Austin yeah he came to the show
and he's like no no bring me up at the
end yeah and then he brought me up and
we [ __ ] around together and had a
great time that's great it was like it
was and I'm not saying that any of these
guys have to do that I'm just saying it
it's nice when they at least give you
the Chappelle like uh yeah man
I'm gonna do four hours you got four
hours and you come back come back at
four in the morning I'll bring you up
what do you guys think about Chris Rock
doing a live special the live special
he's doing he's doing a live Netflix
yeah
um um uh Regan did that for Comedy
Central did he Yeah Yeah
by Will Smith so I don't think there was
a reason yeah
no I think that's cool yeah that's very
cool
um I don't I mean I think it's fine I
love Chris Rock he's my favorite comic I
don't think like a live special I'm like
is that what what's the Allure of that
well Carlin did it for his last like
yeah Carlin did it for like his last six
or seven yeah he did them live but
nowadays you're inviting a protester to
glue himself to the [ __ ] stage
they can't do that though they can't get
into the venue what are they gonna do
right no it feels like more of an event
listen I'm sure he'll have security
right they're going to vet that event
right yeah look what happened all months
ago
I know but nobody thought but that was
different it was a different time I know
you can't will split Smith is a Splinter
Cell yeah or Sleeper Cell yeah sleeper
sounds like you can't you didn't know
nobody knew that was gonna happen yeah
yeah I mean I've seen Chris live plenty
of times I mean he's just great like I
don't see like I don't think there'll be
much of a difference like from it being
recorded in like 30 years later
I think it's a cool thing I think it's a
perfect thing for him to do and I think
it's something look you know this is the
problem with now is even Chris Rock has
to figure out like some yeah you get
people to watch the goddamn thing I mean
it's just like I was gonna watch
regardless so I just think like whatever
I told pimp I'm not going to say it on
air but I told pimp what I'm trying to
do in my new hour and it's like I'm like
doing it because I'm like I don't know
how else to set this aside like I want
to I want to set it aside in my own way
and like it's like you know
a year ago I was like I'll put on
YouTube and now I'm like nope it kind of
It kind of died it went away it went
away pretty quickly right even the clips
man I got a guy that does all my clips
and it's like you know and it's like
it's getting to a point where I'm like
what are we even putting these clips up
for every single person who's ever done
comedy from year one is putting Clips up
from year one to the 30 year old about
yeah an app now to Auto yeah title
everything and and you know and like I'm
again I'm not complaining like time
should be different damn it I'm just
saying like
yeah it gets tough you know like it's
hard not to go eh I don't know it seems
like in this business like every three
years is a new thing that you gotta that
like everyone doing that this is how you
blow up now and you gotta kind of like
three years I think is generous yeah
it's moving faster I think it's yeah
yeah something faster yeah there was a
time where the podcast was the thing
right like it still is now but there was
a time where you had to start a like you
could start a podcast that just blow up
yeah you had to but I think podcasts
we'll see I think the next year is going
to be very really very Telltale about
podcasts you know we'll see they're
gonna shut down Tick Tock that's like
half a comedy who is the government us
government's gonna shut it that they're
trying to yeah so I don't know I don't
have that money followers shut it down
yeah right yeah
let's bring it back to the clubs how
about that you have to have good sets at
the club that's what I'm saying to be
successful but it is funny to judge
comedy by uh who the young Comics are
imitating the most that's how I judge an
errors over and it went from David tell
now it's Shane everyone's doing oh yeah
yeah
yeah
um
so all right let's get to this battle
Shane Torres
James love Shane Torres
let's get to this battle uh I do a chant
forgive me
uh all right folks we will not replace
us
all right
uh-huh he's like I'll be back when I
don't have an HBO yeah
red sauce versus white sauce now I
almost hesitantly
took white sauce in this battle why
because you said you like you love red
sauce and red sauce was something that
you felt passionate about and I wanted
you to be able to argue for something
that you felt passionate about and the
more and I was but at first I was like I
don't know if I I don't know but the
more thought I gave it the more I was
like I I got this i got this I white
sauce is the dominant sauce well to be I
have to be honest to be fair I don't eat
any white sauce so I'm very it's very
one-sided for me I don't need any white
sauce I don't even want to see you eat
it I don't really think I don't think
you like it I go on a date they're like
I'm gonna order this I'm like anything
else you like I don't I don't need this
but but Alfredo sauce I mean what are we
talking about here you're talking about
one dish you're talking about two dishes
spaghetti
or pizza I don't need anything White
racist it's not a race thing it's not
sounds like a race thing it does sound
like a race thing uh most people thought
it was a sex thing like a like uh
homophone not homophobic
don't care like not again like I just I
don't like it doesn't I don't know what
you're thinking this through
because I'm saying you're talking red
sauce red sauce is great red sauce is
great but take me out of the parmesan
pasta and pizza world what are we even
talking about what's it even go on at
that point is that sauce wise yeah what
else buffalo sauce
you're calling the buffalo wing sauce or
red sauce
holy [ __ ]
all right well then uh we listen we can
play by these rules that I'm gonna hit
you a branch and blue cheese I don't
need any of those dude hate them if
we're gonna open it that wide it's white
sauce is white sauce
just alfredo sauce
no it's across the board I was saying if
you're I was doing it by barbecue sauce
not a red sauce dude that's insane it's
literally a red sauce you literally mean
just the color red is it yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah oh you you thought it was like
pasta sauce
[Applause]
no it's the color it's the full color
across the board
comes from a from a bad background
telling him that barbecue sauce was was
gravy
that chip was like a sauce why don't we
I don't need I don't need ketchup that's
the only one I don't eat I don't need
ketchup you don't like ketchup no but I
do like I like a tomato sauce though I
don't wanna listen here's let me let me
start with where I thought you were you
meant when you said red sauce yeah well
I meant that too though no no well
obviously yeah but I thought you you
were saying I was like okay he means red
sauce in a like an Italian restaurant
and I was like okay let me think about
white sauce in just an Italian
restaurant's sake
even there even though I might prefer
a red sauce dish over a white sauce dish
I could argue white sauce all day long
because white sauce is versatility in an
Italian restaurant in my opinion you
have to say here's what I mean you have
to say red sauce Italian restaurant
that's a that's a disclaimer not
disclaimer but that's a qualification
they put on it yeah it's a red sauce
Italian restaurant meaning they do
mostly red sauce on pasta and Parmesan
whatever you go to another Italian
restaurant
you got alfredo sauce but then you've
got all the whites other different
you've got clam sauce you've got mussels
in a white sauce or like a wine a white
wine based sauce versus a marinara it
starts to get pretty expansive and then
I thought to myself if we really wanted
to go crazy and break the rules I could
start to get into things like salad
dressings and I was like there's no way
in hell this lunatic is going to say
barbecue sauce counts as red sauce and
you did so here we are I have it in my
top we're gonna bring every literally
every salad dressing into the mix
because there's no outside of French
dressing there's no red salad dressing
no red are you no it is actually there's
raspberry vinaigrette which is what I
that's not red sauce that is and you
know it's a cheat red sauce has to have
tomato involved in it somewhere well I
just I was going by the color
I was going by the color because it's a
it's a color thing for me Ian this is a
first on taste buds I've never heard a
claim this crazy in my life this is
[ __ ] wild are you doing red versus
white white color across the board I
don't need any I don't need anything we
don't specify that in the poll I don't
need any sauce that's white
so if you want to stay just on Italian
we can but I can you can go to White
vinaigrettes no shower no nothing no
sauce that's white nothing but it's
Italian
that's that's white though no Italian is
like it's not red like yellow
transparent yeah but it's made with
white vinegar
white vinegar is in white the the oil is
the part that makes it a little yellow I
know but like white vinegar is clear
right okay yeah it's a color thing
I'm a colorist but also but also
it's a thing though I'm surprised this
is the first time you're hearing it
because I found out through living life
it's a thing like I'm part of a group of
people that live this way
what is this group of people I found out
people from Queens yeah
the low-class people from Queens
one time I was out of Buffalo Wild Wings
I was ordering uh buffalo wings and the
the waitress asked me she said do you
want Branch or blue cheese I said no I
don't eat white sauce and she was like
oh my God me neither and I said what and
she was like I don't need any type of
sauce that's why and I was with a friend
and she was like she's lying like the
friend was like she's lying she's just
flirting with you but I researched it
and it's a thing it's like a group of
people out there that can't eat white
sauce because of the consistency nobody
has ever referenced
a Buffalo Wild Wings waitress as a point
of information as a source well if you
did that in a courtroom this would be
this bar this was listen you'd be an
awfulness so for the HBO special I
didn't have any credits then I used to
freaking Buffalo Wild Wings a lot more
than I do now so crazy is it though why
is it crazy
let's let's unpack this why is it
is a quitter The Culinary qualifications
to work at a Buffalo Wild Wings I'm just
saying I wasn't saying sommelier of a
sausage I was just saying she pointed
out that that's a world that exists she
works in the food industry she takes a
lot of people's orders she
works in food
at Buffalo Wild Wings listen they're a
thing sure your place you're spoiled
you're from New York City you're spoiled
you go from New York Philly I was at
Kenosha garbage filling
God has good restaurants though where I
was surrounded by garbage ginzos they
weren't making these claims that you're
making right there's good restaurants
you go to Kenosha Wisconsin and Buffalo
Wild Wings is a hard ticket to get you
got to make reservations you gotta know
someone they walk me in like Goodfellas
like the scene in Goodfellas through the
back at Buffalo Wild Wings and sat me
right by the TV don't get me wrong dude
I've spent some time in a Buffalo Wild
Wings dude I'll go in for at the happy
hour and get the wings sit there so why
are you why are you putting this on me
for yourself
as a point of information I would never
I've never cite it as a source for an
argument well this is just as the
waitress it's not what I was thinking
it's the waitress there's a lot of
things I utilize yes that I would never
go let me cite PornHub is a great
example I've never
they love white sauce I don't know
that was easy uh hey some of the videos
are like red sauce too yeah folks listen
this has been you gotta have a
membership for that yeah yeah I don't
get that on the main page uh
so wait what is but where what is your
all right
it started with mayonnaise mayonnaise I
forgot man this is my problem with your
sandwiches buy sandwiches yeah I was
gonna say that up top everyone I I
haven't been to Joyride everyone Raves
about it everyone's like this place is
great only a couple of them have
mayonnaise real I didn't know that I was
like I'm because I won't say no Manny I
know I want to go down there but I was
like do you know how restaurants work
but here's outside of the Buffalo Wild
Wings here's my thing
I I don't think you do here's my thing I
was like everyone talks about how good
the sandwiches are thank you amazing
everyone's like these are the best some
of the best languages I'm not
exaggerating thank you and I love
sandwiches I want to go have a sandwich
but I was like I'm gonna go in there I'm
gonna say no mayonnaise or no white
sauce they're gonna get confused it's
gonna be a whole big thing and then he's
gonna talk about it on the podcast don't
say no white sauce they will know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
she say no mayonnaise say I want this
sandwich or no mayonnaise okay and it's
not there are plenty of sandwiches that
don't have mayonnaise on them or cheese
you can get no cheese if you're all
right I don't need cheese or mayo and I
feel like that's a big staple I I don't
really eat cheese much anymore either uh
and I I have be I've Mayo also has kind
of worked its way for the most part out
of my diet all right so I I in my own
place have to say no cheese no man okay
so what sound I mean what sandwich
should I order because I don't like to
be a problem like you give me a sandwich
it has mayonnaise talk about this on our
own I say nothing all right
to be honest we can turn the cameras off
if you just recommend a sandwich so I
could go have one you said but hold on
you got sidetracked with my sandwiches
which I appreciate but that's not the
point the point is is you said it
started with mayo yes okay how does not
eating Mayo lead to saying I won't eat a
white buttery wine sauce on fish I'll
tell you how it's a good question uh
because I every time I see a white sauce
my brain goes to mayonnaise which I have
a despised for so I can't even fathom
okay that I understand I understand the
uh I have a thing with Foods where if
the person
with certain foods if the person that
brings me a certain I think we've talked
about this in the show if a certain
person
that looks a certain way I don't mean
that in a I don't mean race relax calm
down cool no race no religion
comedians get two cents listen to what
I'm gonna say before you assume I was
already I was getting ready I was
looking at my publicist like we need to
get out of here I just mean
I just mean uh by the way your publicist
brought you to my apartment just sit on
a yellow chair and talk about Manning oh
this is my first special I'm working
I'm working my way up uh shout outs to
Pam Pam's an old friend Pam and I go Way
Way Back
no no I'm good oh wait he makes me sick
this the way you're talking about
mayonnaise I'm gonna be like that with
tea from now on so I'm gonna go because
once I saw Ian Lara drink tea in my
apartment yeah wait what's the type of
people how they look I'm saying a person
that looks a little Grody okay there's
there's people there's just people
sometimes they have it's it's not even
that they're unkept it's not there's
just something physically about a
certain person type sure sure that's
fair I can't even say it's already
disgusted by them
but it's like I don't mean like it's
always a person with this color hair or
it's always a person with it I don't
mean that I just mean there's sometimes
I see a person and the configuration of
elements of that one person I go yeah
and if that type of person if that
person is my waiter or waitress and they
bring me a certain type of food like a
what kind usually something creamy sure
yes get routhed out because for some
reason when I start the picture you
think they made it with their bare hands
and put their feet their fingers in it
yes yes that's exactly yes exactly I get
that yeah if they bring me a burger I
don't care if they're gonna be fries I
don't care mozzarella I don't care but
yeah anything especially with something
that I think could um it is something
creamy because with my cold creamy
because my head goes to um semen
that it could that it could turn oh yeah
so like I I I start to think this person
left it sitting out and it wasn't a
refrigerated properly and that's gross
and I'm like that's where my head starts
to go so I get I actually get what
you're saying the part I don't get is
that you can't get past it is is the
well you can't get past it no no I can't
get past it in that situation yeah well
I mean if you brought me a mayonnaise
sandwich right now I would eat it with
no problem I wouldn't I wouldn't be like
oh like I'm saying when I'd get up and
walk out like like Kanye in an interview
I literally hate mail like I can't stand
it yet but I'm saying I'm saying I
understand getting hung up on a thing
because I can get hung up on a thing
yeah I don't understand the extent to
which you're hung up on it well other
songs I served you a buttery sauce I'm
not eating it
what no no butter melted butter no I'm
not eating it melted butter no hate it
you don't like butter not even on a
steak you know sometimes they put butter
on the steak I say no butter you don't
like butter on toast no
Ian what are you talking about I don't
understand folks I've tried a lot of
deodorants in my day as you might be
able to tell by looking at me
I'm an active man
I'm a pharaoh man some would say uh and
I've tried a lot of Brands and I've had
issues with uh various leading uh
traditional brands of deodorant uh which
is why I like native Native is a really
cool brand I've been using their stuff
for a while now and it really does me
well uh
look at the back of a of a typical uh
the ingredient list of a typical bar of
deodorant there's stuff on there you
can't even pronounce
and if you care about what goes into
your body which you should native is yet
another product that will help you do
that native is aluminum free deodorant
that's it they keep their ingredients
list bare naked uh with ingredients that
you can understand like coconut oil shea
butter
baking soda and it checks a lot of boxes
72-hour period of odor protection
naturally derived ingredients and a
smooth residue-free application I like
that you don't it doesn't leave like you
know white stuff everywhere when you use
native also you're going to smell
amazing they smell so good they smell so
good all right
toasted marshmallow vanilla oh my God it
smells so good uh I've been using native
as I said and I really enjoy it I want
you to use it too because it's a natural
healthy way to stay smelling fresh and
to
you know you know what I mean you know
you know what deodorant's doing for you
try this stuff out anyway smell fresh
and feel fresh all day long with Native
get 20 off your first order by going to
nativedo.com taste buds
uh or you can just use the promo code
taste buds at checkout that's native
deo.com taste buds
or you can just use the promo code taste
buds at checkout and you're going to get
20 off your first order how about that
check it out folks
displayed a one-of-a-kind metal poster
designed to capture your unique Passions
displays created a 21st century canvas
that's sturdy magnet mounted and durable
enough to withstand a lifetime of
intense staring uh here's what I like
about this plate they offer you a lot of
styles and a lot of designs and things
to choose from my my personal favorite
are the or the Retro and vintage ones
because they look there's a lot of old
move movie poster type stuff in there
um but that's just my favorite they've
got a a a a host of Brandon and artistic
artwork over one million designs from
Major Brands like Marvel DC Star Wars
Netflix NASA South Park uh there's
different games the artwork that
represents different games different
movies everybody can find something for
you and then
how it works is you put these safe the
safe magnet mounting mounting system on
your wall which takes like 20 seconds
and then the plates stick to it and then
when you want to change it but you pop
it down mount's still up there boom you
put up a new plate that's how easy
changing artwork is no holes to cover up
nothing like that all right it's great
it's eco-friendly and every design sold
they're going to plant one tree awesome
right now this plate is having its
biggest discount ever one to two disc
plates when you purchase them you get 20
off if you buy three or more you get 30
off use the link in the description and
the discount is automatically applied at
checkout you go to display you go to
displate.com tastebuds that's
d-i-s-p-l-a-t-e.com slash taste buds and
use the code tastebuds at checkout this
plate collect your passions I thought we
were I thought we were understanding I I
I don't eat white sauce Butter's not
white sauce it's cream colored no it's
not it's yellow it's yellow yellow's too
close to White you said you
did you eat yeah but it's a liquid it's
not a sauce
that is
I'm buttering I drink a white liquid
wait that's weird I'll drink milk half
and half I don't have a problem with
that you'll drink milk yeah put butter
on toast no
I don't like the creamy consistency in
like when you're eating it so then maybe
this is less of a color more about
consistency I think it is consistency
but it's colored too
well it's not color all the way well
maybe it's not color because you're
saying yeah look melted butter does not
have the consistency of anything except
melted butter it also is yellow so it's
not hitting either of your two things
like if I get toast I rather have like
olive oil in it than than butter like
you know sometimes they'll put toast
with olive oil at like an Italian
restaurant no garlic bread has olive oil
well garlic well the garlic bread has a
lot of butter on it though the key
ingredient is garlic yeah garlic you
make garlic [ __ ] kidding me no you
butter Italian bread you put Garlic on
it and oregano that's what garlic I
don't believe that when you bake it I
don't believe it you've never stopped to
think why is this bread so delicious I
thought it was the olive oil you think
olive oil makes bread taste like that
are you I mean I literally make it at
home I put olive oil on on Italian bread
and garlic and it's great I mean I'm not
saying you can't do it but garlic like
garlic bread has Butter usually that's
usually I don't know I'll call my people
at Buffalo Wild Wings and see see what
they're doing for the garlic bread
you'll know the dipping the bread and
the olive oil like you do with like
crusty Italian but it's it's fine I I
could take it or leave it there's
nothing beats butter on bread uh in that
circumstance I mean we did a whole
episode about it with with bread she'll
argued that buttered bread was the
greatest I think he argued that it was
the greatest food of all time and I
think he won the debate like you also
wanted to open a restaurant that only
serves buttered bread yes yes yeah
that's not bad
I'd say no butter but just give me the
bread butt
I'm a problem at every restaurant and I
don't want to be because it's very
simple I just people just don't take the
time to understand me but it's very
simple like I eat most things I just
don't eat like three things
okay but three I don't need three
categories of things like well these are
huge categories categories I'll give you
that and I'm telling you you're eating
more butter than you realize I don't
have a problem with butter if I can't
see it or really taste it like I've
fried stuff with butter and you know
like so I don't have a problem I just
probably getting out with eggs I used to
love eggs now I'm eggs for me if eggs is
an ingredient
maybe once in a while I could still eat
eggs but like they just lost their
whatever I got that way with bacon too
we're baking now the only time I want it
is in a BLT or on a bacon cheeseburger
like bacon as a side dish at breakfast
anymore I'm like uh yeah I'm I'm out it
lost me why is that I don't know yeah
I think what about sour cream hate that
too
uh sour cream no I'll [ __ ] sour cream up
on a potato or something like epitome of
like a white
yeah I mean that's hitting all that's
all right that's yeah that's that's
that's that's a no-go for you do you
have vanilla ice cream ice cream yeah
I'll I'll do ice cream I'll do ice cream
but I'm not like a huge fan I'm not one
of those I got news for you too buddy no
key ingredient butter in your precious
[ __ ] hot sauce that you love on hot
dogs is butter yeah I heard that yeah
yeah yeah key ingredient can't taste it
though
um
that's why it tastes good you can taste
it you just don't realize you're tasting
butter if you put regular hot sauce just
on chicken and you ate it next to a
[ __ ] properly prepared hot wing sauce
you would be like
that it is an astoundingly noticeable
difference yeah well there's also
there's also uh there's ketchup and
barbecue sauce I don't eat ketchup but I
like barbecue sauce
well a lot of barbecue sauce you don't a
lot of it you don't need ketchup to
prepare your tomato paste is the base
okay yeah but I love a tomato paste if
you're making it quickly at home
you know if you're gonna like mix some
up fast you're gonna need ketchup but if
you're making barbecue sauce properly
which I've been mocked because I've
actually made my own ketchup before I've
made my own ketchup I would try that
it's not that hard to do but it's just
it's tomato paste like and then you
season it I said it wasn't as good right
it wasn't but I made 30 I did the whole
30 ketchup so it didn't have anything
really truly sweet in it like the thing
I I use diet Heinz now not diet but it
says no sugar addict because they add a
sweetener to it instead of sugar and it
takes all the bad sugar out of it and
but I'll have cancer when I'm [ __ ]
61. sure uh but the point is is like
that like what a lot of people don't
realize is the thing that knocks ketchup
out of the park is the sugar meaning
like the salt yeah like Heinz Ketchup
which was determined the most perfect
tasting food in a study by scientists
really meaning there was the most yeah
it's official yeah it was it was they
did a study and they said that Heinz 57
Ketchup was the most perfectly balanced
flavored food like on the planet like it
was the most perfectly it hit everything
and the reason that for that I want to I
want to like I want to light ketchup I
don't understand why you don't like
ketchup dude yeah me neither that's a
weird one to me what is your favorite
food Pizza okay okay why okay and I
don't eat cheese just on Pizza only okay
is that weird
like I won't even eat it without you
it's [ __ ] weird I won't need a
chicken farm I won't eat a chicken part
but I like pizza I love pizza your
chicken parm is pizza except the crust
is chicken but it's the issue and I love
chicken what is the issue dude maybe I'm
more complicated what are you talking
about it got more complicated than I
thought
dude you're going to Crazy lengths man
like I like listen this is like hard
when I date like if when I'm dating
somebody like I get a new girlfriend or
whatever I just send it like this is it
like I just I I eat pizza like don't ask
don't make it weird I just eat pizza I
don't like cheese but I eat pizza that's
it that's the only cheese don't tell me
lasagna my friends God is like that he
won't he only eats Pizza on cheese
because it's one of the only his thing
is it's one of the only cheat for
whatever reason and I get this because I
have I have growing lactose issues as I
get older yeah there's something about
melted mozzarella on Pizza where a lot
of the time it doesn't set off your
lactose issues it's got to be something
with the way mozzarella was made yeah
but I'm not even lactose I just don't
like it I'm not like well he he hates
cheese but also does have lactose stuff
yeah but but he makes sense he loves
pizza though yeah love it but then also
too he only will eat plain pizza whereas
like there's other food like but he
loves pepperoni but he won't he he
doesn't like pepperoni pizza he likes
you know what I mean yeah it's a little
calm but it gets complicated that's
that's all just that's tough but I get
to the no mixing of foods too like
that's that's I have things where that I
love but I won't mix them because yeah
like for instance I like mayonnaise
hot mayonnaise oh [ __ ] what's hot
mayonnaise meaning like jalapeno
mayonnaise
or hot water oh that's disgusting like I
don't like tuna melts I don't like and I
love tuna fish I hate tuna melts I don't
like um I love cheese steaks if people
put it it's gross it's gross if people
want mayonnaise on a Cheesesteak I'll
barf
yeah it's gross I can have mayonnaise on
a burger but it has to be like separated
by like the lettuce and tomato so it
stays cool
yeah maybe I am a soft comedian I can't
even sit here and have hot mayonnaise
talking this is I'm offended by that
more than any jokes episode we're doing
our next episode Corinne and uh
Christina from the guys we [ __ ] are
coming in
in a few minutes actually uh to do uh
we're doing truffle yay or nay
nay for me but well yeah and is it bad
if I tease who's on what team no no so
Christina loves truffle me and Corinne
hate it yeah so we're with us versus
Christina and I'm a plain guy said she's
like I might need a trash can for this
conversation I'll [ __ ] puke yeah yeah
I'm like that with me like I'm like I
just like playing stuff like I'm okay
with like I'll get a sandwich like
honestly when I go to like a deli like a
queen's Deli to get a sandwich this is
what I get on the sandwich is Turkey
lettuce tomatoes salt pepper that's it
that's probably your this one of the
reasons you're in such good shape
because you're a kid that grew up eating
like that when you don't eat when you
eat like that from being a young from a
young age and you don't like all the bad
[ __ ]
what a that's that's that's like that's
in my opinion that's equivalent to like
playing sports as a kid yeah I'm behind
the eight ball on both because I didn't
play sports as a kid and I loved like
cheeseburgers and bad [ __ ] but like I
like hamburgers I just don't like cheese
like I just but I'm saying I eat pretty
bad dude eating a hamburger without
ketchup or cheese on it Jesus Christ yes
okay you're cutting out all the sugar
you're cutting out all the sugar and
you're cutting out a huge portion of the
cholesterol and saturated fat and
whatever by cutting out those other
things dude you go to Burger King and
get
that's how my buddy is he when he would
get a burger he would get lit he would
use ketchup but he would get a plain
burger or on a [ __ ] bun that's how he
and then he's eventually started putting
lettuce and tomato on on it and stuff
one time I ordered a burger I think it
was at Burger King I was like on the
road I forgot where I was I went to a
Burger King and I ordered a burger and
like I just wanted like plain I just
wanted like lettuce tomatoes and a
burger no ketchup no mayo they were so
like they couldn't fathom what I ordered
they gave me a bun with lettuce and
tomatoes no Patty dude it's crazy like
they couldn't fathom no mail it's crazy
how for a loop like in the uniform like
chain places people I I have a problem
and we got to go to the phones pimp uh I
go I I I have a problem every time I
order a coffee
and I have the problem more
at Starbucks than I have anywhere else
because it's a chain yeah
I say the same thing every time
Americano medium black
a little bit of ice please just a little
bit of ice so it's not too hot and I say
it exactly like that a little bit of ice
so it's not and they just they can't two
people two different people every time
almost will say to me so wait you want
to you want an iced America no I want an
Americano with a little bit of ice just
so you could drink it right away it's
not too hot yeah
it's insane their mind is like yeah I
don't understand how this hasn't come I
don't get how it doesn't come up how did
you figure out you like that order
because I like black coffee and I don't
know if uh if you've ever tried to drink
black coffee served directly to you from
any chain restaurant it's made for Satan
him for himself it's insane but I never
thought ice cubes is what I might need
time away from this if you don't put
cream in it then nothing cools at all
that's actually that makes sense wait a
minute I have a question I have a quick
question about the Americano is
Americano Just a black coffee
uh no no Americano is uh is espresso two
shots of espresso with hot water in it
to dilute it a bit oh because I was I
remember when I went to Europe I get
like a black coffee a little bit of
cream I was ordering black coffee they
didn't know what that was because
espresso is almost the only game in town
and I didn't even know that I was like
what do you mean a black coffee like
it's just coffee yeah yeah if you get
over if you get coffee from overseas
like for home I mean if you just buy it
around I got Colombian it's just
espresso yeah yeah almost all of it is
just espresso you know but but but yeah
that that's you you can't and then
and I've dealt with the Doh now uh that
we've opened the Department of Health
yeah oh sorry Homeland Security and like
what'd you do no dude like like the
rules for how the reason I'm learning
the reason that that all these things
are at these temperatures is because the
Department of Health rules for like what
something is allowed to sit at for
whatever period it has to be boiling
it's so strict
whatsoever in one one millionth of a
millionth of a millionth chance that any
bacteria could ever form ever
happens that's why when you go get a
coffee the standing [ __ ] temperature
of it is literally enough to burn your
skin I can't imagine a black coffee no
cream like because with cream I got it
with cream and it is I have to wait 20
minutes before I take a sip that's weird
oh yeah you totally you said it already
this half and half it's just milk let's
go to the phones pip we got we got to do
this quick what people call in daddy is
right no no that's what we call going
with the comments on Twitter white uh
white sauce is the cream soda of sauces
wow
with me well they might that could be a
degree or disagreement yeah some people
like cream soda yeah I'm not sure
no idea what white sauce even is that's
a lot of comments here that's good red
sauce is going to win this I know it
already yeah obviously yeah red sauce is
like a hug from your grandmother white
sauces for socialites exactly it's a
pretentious thing white Chargers
that's really funny for industry
[Music]
adults bringing white sauce to your
mouth this is a landslide
I know listen I like I saw the top I
love red sauce and if I had to pick one
like in a preference like it just mean
like which one do I prefer because I
like those dishes more frequently it's
definitely red sauce for me sure but
once you expand it past the initial
dishes I thought and you thought like we
brought into dressings and all that
stuff then I would have to go white
because you're you're getting you're
getting into a whole new world as far as
I'm concerned but but that's very
different from but not really because
you don't like Mayo no I do like Mayo
you don't eat it no more no I don't need
any more for dietary reasons yeah
Buffalo you eat buffalo sauce and
barbecue sauce and ketchup
yeah uh yeah I don't eat barbecue sauce
a ton I eat it less than I eat Mayo
because it's loaded with sugar it is
right a lot of sugar yeah yeah I still
eat Mayo a bit I just I just I regulate
it yeah
uh red sauce feels like putting a
sweatshirt on fresh out of the dryer
beautiful white sauce tastes like
froth baby pool water that's not good
that's honestly a pretty good analogy
Norman that's a good one
took a bit he had yeah uh somebody said
it the choices between common blood
that's the winner that's the winner I go
blood that's the winner put it up in the
episode I lost track of it in all the
comments you don't have one person that
like sided with the white
uh well we don't know we'll see this
could be a bad this is gonna be bad all
right oh you know who tweeted that fat
mommy who was gonna get the DeRosa
stinks tattoo oh really yeah yeah all
right follow that mommy also by the way
fat mommy yeah you got my blessing knock
yourself out get the tattoo I don't give
a [ __ ] what am I gonna tell him not to
do it one of the fans is gonna get the
same tattoo he got for Keith Robinson oh
that keeps yeah he wants to get jota
Rosa stinks on his arm get it I'm
flattered I'm flattered tell him we
should respond to that tweet and say go
ahead do it all right cool yeah you have
our blessing all right uh we just say
the winner
you have any plugs beside your special
uh no just follow I mean go watch the
specials on HBO Max and Lara romantic
comedy and follow me on Instagram me and
Lyle live at my website I'm going on the
road next year full year bunch of dates
all up on my website ianlive.com all
right good uh we have a whoever wins has
to say I love you I still love you and
then I the other person says I love you
back
that's it once I announce the winner
love
joke
uh I uh I want I still love you no no
you don't we don't know who won yet oh I
thought
there's a poll oh there's a poll yeah
yeah
all right ready pimps winner with 67 is
red sauce okay wow 67 a little less than
I thought it was going to be oh God it's
kind of close yeah yeah a little less
than I thought it was going to be all
righty and congrats you won your first
episode of taste buds yep uh I still
love you man I love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate